[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله حيث
يستمر تصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
حصار القوات الاحتلال وعملياتها تتركز في
الساعات الماضيه على محيط اريحا ونابلس
هذه صور تاتينا من كيف بينما تعلن قياده
القوات الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه
تواصل التقدم على الجبهه بخموت وهي
المدينه التي توصف بانها ام المعارك في
السيطره على الشرق الاوكراني اما هذه
الصور فتصلنا من واشنطن والتوتر على اشده
بين الولايات المتحده والصين على اكثر من
صعيد اجراءات واجراءات مضاده في حرب
متعدده الاوجه تتابعون تفاصيلها في الحصاد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
الطاقه الذريه تقول في تقرير اطلعت عليه
الجزيره انها عثرت في ايران على جزيئات
ايرانيوم بنسبه تخصيب عاليه تناهز تسعين
في المئه وهي النسبه اللازمه لصنع قنبله
نوويه واشنطن تقول ان طهران زادت من تخصيب
اليورانيوم منذ انسحاب واشنطن من الاتفاق
النووي والوزير الخارجيه الايرانيه يقول
ان واشنطن غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار شجاع
بالعوده للاتفاق النووي
على وقع معارك الشرق الجيش الاوكراني يؤكد
تقدم القوات الروسيه في باخموت ويعلن عزمه
ارسال تعزيزات اضافيه
[موسيقى]
تقول انها تواصل تقدمها موسكو تعلن احباط
هجوم اوكراني كبير بالطائرات المسيره على
شبه جزيره القرم واشنطن تتحدث عن وجود
اجزاء امريكيه المصدر في مسيرات وصواريخ
سقطت في اوكرانيا
في فصل جديد من التوتر مع الصين لجنه في
مجلس النواب الامريكي توافق على مشروع
قانون يسمح بحظر تطبيق تيك توك مسؤول في
الاف بي اي يرجح فرضيه تسرب بفيروس كورونا
من مختبر صيني وبيجين تشكك في مصداقيه
الاستنتاجات الامريكيه وتقول انها تلاعب
سياسي
[موسيقى]
فرد وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان الفلسطينيه
استشهد متاثرا بجروح حرجه اصيب بها برصاص
الاحتلال خلال اقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر في
مدينه اريحا وقد انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من داخل المخيم بعد ان اقتحمته
بحجه اعتقال منفذي الهجوم المسلح الذي ادى
الى مقتل مستوطن الاثنين الماضي واعتقلت
سته فلسطينيين واصابت اخرين ووسطت قوات
الاحتلال الحصار بلده حواره والقرى
القريبه جنوبيه نابلس منذ الاحد الماضي
مره اخرى تخرق السلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كل التفاهمات السياسيه ففي
واضح النهار اقتحمت مخيم عقبه جابر في
اريحا قوه مستعربين تسللت بسياره فلسطينيه
مدعومه بحشد من جنود واليات الاحتلال
حاصروا منزلا اصابوا فلسطينيين بالرصاص
اعتقلوا عددا اخر
واحتجزوا ابا وطفله كدرع بشري بعدها
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال من داخل المخيم
متلقيه تهاني وزير الدفاع ومبقيه حواجز
عسكريه تطوق المحافظه
اما في حوار الجنوبيه نابلس فابقى
الاحتلال حصاره العسكري عليها منذ الاحد
الماضي حواره التي صرح زعيم الصهيونيه
الدينيه بوجوب محوها من الوجود
يجب محو قريه حوار من الارض على اسرائيل
القيام بذلك وليس المدنيين
رئيس الحكومه الفلسطينيه زار مع وفدا من
الوزراء البلده وصف ما وقع فيها الاحد
الماضي بالجريمه اسرائيل الان تريد اعاده
انتاج النكبه سواء كان على شكل مذابح او
سواء كان على شكل تهجير او غيره لذلك
رسالتنا واضحه لا نكرر ما جرى في التاريخ
احنا موجودين هون على ارضنا صامدين
اما الحصار العسكري المتواصل لقريه ضمن
قرى تربط شمال الضفه الغربيه بوسطها فثبت
الاهالي خسائر ماليه فادحه وانسانيه صعبه
سرطان دور مش قادر اجيبها الدور يعني ما
يخلف رئيس البلديه عبالي مي بصعوبه وصلته
اعطاني عبالي مي يعني الوضع عندنا ماساه
ماساه ماساه طلع لنا طلع المستوطنين طلع
الجيش على راسي عليهم
مشاهدوا دفعت مؤسسات وفعاليات الى التحذير
مما هو قادم نحن مقبلين على مجازر ومحارق
قادمه لا محاله المستوطنين حملوا السلاح
باذن من حكومتهم ووزعوا السلاح وهم
ارهابيين مدربون يساعد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عمليات القتل والحرق والتدمير
والتهجير ويمارس اجراءات انتقاميه بحق
الاسرى ويفرض عقوبات جماعيه ويرى
الفلسطينيون في الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
جرائم مكتمله بغطاء سياسيا وامنيا من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه الجزيره من
بلده حواره جنوبينابلس
هذا وداعا المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو لادانه تصريحات وزيره وزيره في
الماليه المتعلقه بقريه حواره وصف برايس
تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
التي دعا فيها الى محوي قريه حواره
بالمقززه وغير المسؤوله
والمحرضه على العنف
معنا من رام الله علي الجرباوي والساده
العلوم السياسيه في جماعه بيرزيت
ومعنا من الناصره دكتور السليم بريك
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه دكتور
جرباوي ما هو المتوقع في المرحله المقبله
المتوقع هو الصيد لانه الان نحن نواجه
دوله
المستوطنين المستوطنين يحميهم الجيش
يحميهم دوله اسرائيل ولكن هم يشكروا دوله
يعني خاصه بهم وياخذ القانون على يعني
بايديهم ولذلك من المتوقع ان تزداد عمليات
هجومه على الكره وعلى الطرق وعلى
الفلسطينيين بشكل عام ومن هذا يعني ولذلك
سيكون هناك المزيد من الضغط على الشعب
الفلسطيني خصوصا كلما جرت عمليه منفرده من
قبل فلسطيني الوضع الفلسطيني وضع صعب لانه
الفلسطينيون الان لم يبقى لديهم امل باي
مستقبل على الاطلاق وخصوصا الشباب لذلك
الشباب الفلسطيني يعني من كل شاب منه
لحاله بدون ما يكون في اي يعني تنظيم واي
فصيل فيها ايه يعني من الضغط الاقتصادي
والسياسي يقوم بعمليات منفرده هذه
العمليات لا تستطيع اسرائيل ان تتبعها ولا
ان تسيطر عليها ولذلك ردات الفعل ستكون
يعني من قبل المستوطنين وخصوصا وان هناك
حكومه هي حكومه مستوطنين وحكومه يمينيه
متطرفه جدا هدفها ان تتوغل وان تنهي وضع
الضفه نهائيا لذلك سيكون هناك تصعيد بدون
شك يعني دكتور سليم كيف يفكر الاسرائيليون
هل بالفعل يعتقدون ان هذه الاجراءات التي
يتخذونها سوف تكون رادعه
للفلسطينيين والعمليات التي يقومون بها
في تغيير في الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه
التغيير هو
بدل ان يكون رد فعل حسب وجهه نظر
الاسرائيليه ان يكون فيها الاستباقي اي
انه قبل ان يقوم الفلسطينيين باي اعمال ضد
اسرائيل يجب على اسرائيل ان تقوم باعمال
التي هي ترهب الفلسطينيين وتمنعهم مستقبل
من القيام باي عمليات عسكريه عمليا
اسرائيل قلقه جدا من الفتره القريبه وفتره
الاعياد خصوصا رمضان المبارك ولذلك
الاستراتيجيه التي تبناها الجيش واجهزه
الامن هي عمليا امتصاص الغضب ومحاوله
التهدئه وعلى هذا الاساس كانت تنسيق بين
الامريكيين للذهاب الى العقبه ولكن ما حدث
بان الحكومه الاسرائيليه الان محكومه من
قبل المستوطنين اللي سمعنا تصريحاته
الذين يسيطرون على بنيامين نتنياهو
ويفرضون عليه السياسه من ناحيه ومن ناحيه
ثانيه الان المستوطنين يسي على الجيش يعني
في الفتره الاخيره هناك هجوم على الجنود
الاسرائيليين من قبل المستوطنين هذه امور
يعني تقريبا غير مسبوقه وهذا يؤدي الى
تصعيد اكثر فاكثر في المناطق الفلسطينيه
وخصوصا بان اعضاء التلاف عمليا مسعورين
نحن باكثر من مره سمعنا بالفتره الاخيره
تصريحات اللي هي غير غير منطقيه وغير
مقبوله في اي مكان في العالم
لا يوجد رد حقيقي لهذه التصرفات
الاسرائيليه من قبل العالم والدول المحيطه
ولذلك هذا يشجع اسرائيل على استمرار فيما
تقوم به ابقى ابقى معنا من فضلكم الاقتحام
اليوم تضمن مشهدا طرحه كثيرا من الاسئله
حيث اكد شهود عيان داخل مخيم عقبه جبر ان
قوات الاحتلال اتخذت مدنيين دروعا بشريه
اظهرت صور توقيف قوات الاحتلال لرجل يحمل
طفلا الى جانب عربه عسكريه يتجمع حولها
جنود الاحتلال خلال دخولهم للمخيم
من جانبها قالت مقرره الامم المتحده
الخاصه بحقوق الانسان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
انها ستحقق في واقعه استخدام قوات
الاحتلال لدروع بشريه خلال اقتحامها مخيم
عقبه جبر وخلال مقابله مع الجزيره اكدت
المقرره الامميه ان استخدام الدروع
البشريه من الممارسات الشائعه لدى قوات
الاحتلال
اسرائيل بصفتها قوه احتلال لديها مسؤوليه
حمايه حياه المدنيين سنحقق في هذه القضيه
وما حدث في مخيم عقبه جبر واؤكد ان
استخدام الدروع البشريه ممارسه شائعه من
قبل اسرائيل منذ عام
1967 فنرى استخدام مدنيين فلسطينيين
الوقوف امام الجنود وكذلك ان يطلب منهم
قرع الباب قبل الاقتحام منذ عام 2000
حاولت اسرائيل اتهام الفلسطينيين بانهم هم
من يستخدمون الدروع البشريه والحقيقه ان
اسرائيل هي من تقوم بذلك وعليه يجب اثبات
وتوثيق مثل هذه الممارسات التي تقوم بها
اسرائيل
يعرف القانون الدولي الدروع البشريه
يعرفها بانها وضعوا مجموعه من الناس
مدنيين او عسكريين بشكل متعمد حول الاهداف
العسكريه لردع العدو عن مهاجمتها وقد ياخذ
الدرع البشري اشكالا اخرى كوضع المدنيين
او الرهائن امام قوات متقدمه لمنع العدو
من التصدي لها كما يصنف في خانه الدروع
البشريه تخزين اسلحه ومعدات وتمركز وحدات
عسكريه مقاتله في مناطق ماهوله بالمدنيين
يجرب القانون الدولي اقدام الاطراف
المتنازعه في الصراعات والحروب على
استخدام الدروع البشريه وفق اتفاقيه جنيف
عام 1929 وعام
والبروتوكول الاضافي لها عام
1977 وايضا معاهده روما عام 1998
تحقيق لنيورك تايمز افاد بان الجنود
الاسرائيليين استخدموا القوه المميته ضد
الفلسطينيين العزل في نابلس في الثاني
والعشرين من فبراير الماضي مما اسفر عن
مقتل اربعه اشخاص على الاقل واضافت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز في تحقيقها ان من استهدفهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يبدو انهم يشكلون
تهديدا
هذا واتهم رئيس الحكومه بين يمينه نياهو
احزابا معارضه اسرائيليه بعدم المسؤوليه
وذلك على خلفيه احتجاجات عنيفه ضد الحكومه
وقال نتنياهو في كلمه له في القدس الغربيه
ان حكومته لا تقبل بالعنف سواء في حواره
او في تل ابيب
وقال مدير المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه هذا هذا في موضوع اخر سنعود
اذا
لضيفين الدكتور علي الجرباوي بدايه ما
تعليقك على هذه الصور التي شاهدناها
لاستخدام دروع
البشريه يعني شكل لابسه فيه ولا جدال طفل
وضع امامه هذا الجندي الاسرائيلي
يعني اسرائيل تقوم باكثر من ذلك القوات
الاسرائيليه الجيش الاسرائيلي كل يوم يقوم
باكثر من ذلك
ولا يوجد اي كابح امام تصرفات الجنود
الاسرائيليين الاسرائيليين نحن نحن لسنا
بحاجه الى اثباتات جديده الاثباتات موجوده
ولكن حتى لو تم تحقيق في هذا الامر وحتى
لو توصلت الامم المتحده بان هذا الكلام
صحيح ما الذي ستفعله الامم المتحده
اسرائيل محميه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولذلك طالما هي محميه من قبل
الدوله العظمى في العالم معنى ذلك انها
تاخذ لنفسها تصريحا بان تقوم بما تشاء
بدون اي يعني كوابح وهي لا تسال عن احد لا
تسال عن
المجتمع الدولي لا تسال عن المؤسسات
الدوليه لا تسال عن الدول في الاقليم لا
تسال عن احد لانها محميه
اذا ما تغير راي الولايات المتحده هذا
سيكون كافي لان تتغير كل المنظومه
يعني التي تعيش اسرائيل ضمنها ولكن هذا لم
يحصل حتى الان ويعني من الصعب ان يحصل في
القريب العاجل دكتور سليم باعتبارك خبيرا
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه نريد ان نفهم كيف
يتعامل الاسرائيليون مع مشهد كهذا لانه
مهما كان الامر لابد ان هناك حدا ادنى من
الانسانيه لا يمكن لبشر ان يقبل تصرفا من
هذا النوع استخدام الاطفال كدروع بشريه
بشكل واضح وجلي
مع الاسف الوضع باسرائيل يعني نحن موجودين
بازمه فاشيه حقيقيه اعتقادي غالبيه
المواطنين باسرائيل لا يهتمون ولا يكترثون
بهذه الصور التي نراها
عمليا كل احتلال في العالم ونحن شفنا هاي
الشغله مثلا في الجزائر واماكن اخرى
الاحتلال يستند على نزع الانسانيه من
المحتل يعني انت لا تستطيع ان تسيطر على
شعب وتحتله الا اذا نزعت عنه صفه
الانسانيه وهذا ما يحدث للفلسطينيين يعني
غالبا لا يكترث احد بما يحدث مع
الفلسطينيين قتل ابرياء الصور التي
رايناها حاليا قليل جدا من الاسرائيليين
يهتمون في هذا الموضوع الحل يجب ان يكون
من الخارج وليس من داخل دوله اسرائيل
والحل يجب ان يكون تدخل دول مثلا كان
الاجتماع في العقبه الذي رعته الولايات
المتحده فاذا ماذا حدث لماذا الولايات
المتحده
لا تقول شيء عن هذه الاهانه لها من قبل
او على سبيل المثال ماذا تفعل مصر في هذا
الموضوع وماذا تفعل الاردن في هذا الموضوع
نحن نرى الدول العربيه في الفتره الاخيره
تتعامل وكانها طرف ثالث وليس طرف شقيق
للشعب الفلسطيني القضيه الثانيه انه من
الفتره الاخيره خصوصا منذ بدايه التطبيع
او ما يسمى
اسرائيل يعني اصبحت اكثر حريه واكثر
استعدادا لكل هذه الصور التي نراها
باعتبار انها تتوسع في العالم العربي ولا
ترى اي اهتمام بشان الفلسطيني وعلى مع
الاسف الفلسطينيين بقوا يعني متروكين
لانفسهم لا احد يهتم بهم ولا احد يهتم
بحقوقهم وهذا ما يحدث على ارض الواقع
كنتيجه لهذا الامر دكتور جرباوي هل يمكن
ان يكون الحل لن ياتي الحل من الخارج مع
تصريح مثلا لمقرره الامم المتحده التي
قالت انها ستحقق في هذه الواقعه التي
نتحدث عنها
لا اظن ذلك يعني المجتمع الدولي
لا يريد او لا يستطيع حل هذا الصراع ولذلك
هو يريد ادارته باقل تكلفه ممكنه لذلك هو
سيحاول دائما ان يعني كلما كان هناك عدم
استقرار ان يعيد الوضع الى سابق عهده الان
نحن نشهد هبه في داخل الارض المحتله وهناك
يعني امكانيه تصاعد العنف كل العالم سيكون
يعني مشغول باعاده الامور الى مستواها
الاصلي وليس الى ايجاد حل لهذا الصراع
المديد ولكن النقطه المهمه انه الشعب
الفلسطيني لم يبقى لديه امل في المستقبل
حتى ينتظر وحتى يتم تخديره حاليا باجراءات
تسكينيه من اجل يعني اعاده الوضع الى
العنف او مستوى الى مستوى ادنى
سيتم تستم هذه المحاوله ولكن دون اتخاذ
اجراءات رادعه باتجاه اسرائيل اسرائيل
تتصرف بدون كوابح وليس هناك من يرتاحها
حتى الان ويبدو بانه لن يكون هناك من
يردعها في مدى المنظور شكرا جزيلا لكم من
رام الله على الجرباوي استاد العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت ومن الناصره
الدكتور سليم بريك الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه
ومن واشنطن معنا مراسل جزيره ناصر الحسين
ناصر اذا استمعنا الى المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه وقال عن تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي بانها مقززه لسنا معتدين ابدا
على مثل هذه اللهجه فيما يخص الاسرائيليين
عندما ياتي الامر واشنطن
نعم بالفعل هذه لغه جديده والظاهر وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه بدات تضيق درعا الان
بالتصرفات الاسرائيليه وخاصه تلك
التصريحات العلنيه لمجموعه من المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين في حكومه واليوم في تصريحات
نت برايس بالفعل موقفا امريكيا مستاءا
ولنقل مستاء جدا جدا اذا ترجمه حرفيا
كلمات فهو قال ان تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه بخصوص محو قريه الحوره غير
مسؤوله مقززه وتدعو للعنف وهذا يعارض
تماما ما تدعو له الولايات المتحده واشنطن
ومنذ الاسابيع القليله الماضيه وادراكا
منها للتدور الاوضاع الامنيه بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين سارعت كبرائينا
في قمه العقبه وفي جهود اخرى صرعت بالفعل
الى محاوله الضغط على الجانب الاسرائيلي
كي وقف بعضا من العنف الموجه الفلسطينيين
ادراكا منها ان مجيء شهر رمضان المقبل
الانهيار
خدمات الفلسطينيين انعدام الامن بشكل
مستمر الفلسطينيين بدا الان يعطي الولايات
المتحده والاسرائيليين والعالم الغربي هذا
المشهد شبه يومي الان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله الذي تجاوز حقيقه حتى
قدرات السلطات السلطه الفلسطينيه هناك
الشعور في واشنطن ان الوضع الامني بدا
ينزلق ولهذا تاتي حتى من دوله حليفه مثل
الولايات المتحده تلك العبارات الشديده
الدبلوماسيا لا شك ان الولايات المتحده
تدرك صعوبه الموقف ولكنها ايضا تدرك ايضا
على ما يبدو بين الجانب الاسرائيلي هنا
تجاوز بعضا من الخطوط الحمراء المرسومه
فيما يخص التعامل مع الجانب الفلسطيني
والولايات المتحده بشكلها الحالي واداره
الحاليه تقول صراحه الان للجانب
الاسرائيلي انها غير مستعده لقبول تصريحات
تصفها بالمقززه بغير مسؤوله والتصريحات
ايضا كما قلنا ستؤدي الى العنف وبال
نبغه وتربى عاش في الولايات المتحده يتحدث
الانجليزيه بلكنه يفهمها الامريكيون وهناك
نوع من التفاهم معنى نياهو والمشكله حسب
كثير من المراقبين هنا في الولايات
المتحده الان تتعامل مع حكومه توصف
باليمنيه والمتطرفه اعضائها لا يعرفون
الولايات المتحده والولايات المتحده لا
تعرفهم واقل شيء في كل هذا انهم يتحدثون
بالانجليزيه
لا يتعرف عليها الامريكيون بشكل او باخر
حتى الامريكي والان يكتشفون وجها اخر
لاسرائيل واجا اخر لحكومه نتنياهو ما تبقى
من امل لدى الامريكيين ان نتنياهو يتمكن
بشكلنا او باخر من لجنه حجم التصريحات
التي تصاب بالعنصريه كما سمعنا في حاله
هواره لكن ايضا مجموعه من التصريحات
الاخرى على مدى الايام القليله الماضيه
بوعيده قمه العقبه التي تحدث العقبه
وقراراتها وبالتالي لنفهم من هذه
التصريحات نوعا من خيبه الامل الامريكيه
ونوعا من الرساله الموجهه بشكل خاص الى
متناعه في وجه الخاص شكرا جزيلا لكم
واشنطن مراسل الجزيره ناصر الحسين
[موسيقى]
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه في تقرير اطلعت عليه الجزيره ان
نتائج تحليل عينات في منشاه فوردو اظهرت
وجود جزيئات يورانيوم على الطقس عالي
التخصيب بنسبه
83.7 من اليورانيوم واضاف التقرير الذي
قدمه المدير العام لمجلس المحافظين ان
الوكاله ابلغت ايران ان هذه النتائج غير
متسقه مع مستوى التخصيب الذي اعلنته طهران
مطالبه بتوضيح مصدر جسيمات اليورانيوم
معالي التخصيب واشارت تقرير الى ان
الوكاله لم تتمكن من القيام بمهام التحقق
والرصد المنصوص عليها في الاتفاق النووي
سواء فيما يتعلق بانتاج وجرد اجهزه الطرد
المركزي او انتاج الماء الثقيل او تخصيب
اليورانيوم لمده عامين وافاد التقرير ان
موظ في الوكاله لم تكن لهم القدره على
التفتيش اليومي حسب الطلب كما ينص على ذلك
الاتفاق لمفاعلاتنا تانس وفورد
كما قال التقرير ان مفتشي الوكاله لم يكن
بامكانهم التثبت من ان اجهزه الطرد
المركزي وبنياتها التحتيه المخزنه قد بقيت
في مخازنها ام تم استعمالها لتعويض
الاجهزه المتضرره وذكر التقرير ان
المفتشين لم يستطيعوا التثبت من كميات
المواد التي دخلت في مراحل عمليات التخصيب
لحسابها بدقه وعزت تقرير هذا القصور الى
ما قال انه قرار ايراني بازاله جميع معدات
الوكاله التي سبق تركيبها في ايران لانشطه
المراقبه والرصد
وختم التقرير بان هذه الاحداث تحد من قدره
الوكاله على الكشف والابلاغ في الوقت
المناسب
هذا وذكرت وكاله انباء فارس ان مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافاييل
جروسي سيصل الى طهران الجمعه ومن المتوقع
ان يلتقي جروسي الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيسي حيث كان جروسي قد اكد في الاسابيع
الاخيره انه لن يزور طهران الا اذا كان
بامكانه مقابله الرئيس الايراني
في الملف ذاتي يا خالد المندوبه الامريكيه
في الامم المتحده ليندا توماس جرين فيلدن
ايران زادت التخصيب اليورانيوم منذ انسحاب
واشنطن من الاتفاق النووي وجددت كريم في
التاكيده على ان الاداره الامريكيه لن
تسمح بحصول ايران على سلاح نووي من جانبه
من جانب اخر نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين
بان كلا من وزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه
ومستشار الامن القومي الاسرائيلي سيزوراني
واشنطن لاجراء مباحثات تركز على ايران
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد
الله هيان قال في مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان
بلاده كانت ولا تزال الاكثر التزاما من
بين جميع الاطراف المشاركه في مفاوضات
الملف النووي واتهم عبد الهيان الولايات
المتحده بانها تتبنى سلوكا مخادعا
فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق النووي كانت ايران
ولا تزال الاكثر التزاما الطرف الذي انسحب
منه هو ترامب والولايات المتحده على
الولايات المتحده الا تتبنى سلوكا مخادعا
وان تعود بدلا من ذلك الى الاتفاق وتتبنى
نهجا بناء فضل الحكومه الجديده للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه قررنا مواصله الحوار
من اجل العوده الى الاتفاق واجرينا
مناقشات طويله للغايه في فيينا قالت
الولايات المتحده انها في مرحله التوصل
الى اتفاق لكن الايرانيين يطالبون باكثر
من اللازم صراحه في السنوات القليله
الماضيه راينا ان المسؤولين الامريكيين
غير قادرين على اتخاذ قرار بسبب مشاكلهم
الداخليه والضغوط التي يتعرضون لها
جدل يعود للواجهه بعد تقارير قالت ان
وكاله الطاقه الذريه اكتشفت ماده يورانيوم
مخصب بدرجه نقاء تبلغ نحو 84% في احد
المواقع الايرانيه فما الذي يعنيه ذلك
الاتفاق النووي كان ينص على ان تخصب ايران
اليورانيوم بنسبه لا تتجاوز ثلاثه وسته
اعشار في المئه لاحقا وفظا لتعليق الاتفاق
الذي انسحبت منه واشنطن خلال فتره الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب اعلن استهران زياده
نسبه التخصيب الى نحو 60% نسبه
84% اضحت قريبه جدا من تحقيق ما يعرف
بالعتبه النوويه اي ان الوصول الى
يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه نقاء يربح بين 90
وخمسه وتسعين في المئه يفسح المجال امام
صناعه قنبله النوويه يضاف الى ما سبق شرط
ضروري وهو كميه اليورانيوم حيث تتطلب
قنبله واحده نحو 25 كيلو غراما من هذا
اليورانيوم
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا من الطهران محمد صالح صدقيان
الباحث المتخصص في القضايا الاقليميه ومن
واشنطن مايلز بامبر كبير الباحثين في مركز
جيمس مارتن لدراسات الحد من الانتشار
النووي اهلا وسهلا بكما كان ذلك ايضا
سابدا بك السيد محمد صالح صدقيان
سي بي اس
تنسب الى مسؤول امريكي
رفيع قوله ان طهران باتت على بعد 12 يوما
فقط من
تكون هناك قنبله نوويه
كيف تعلق على تصريح من هذا النوع
مساء الخير لك
المشاهدين انا اعتقد بان مثل هذه
التصريحات هي تريد ان تضغط على ايران وهي
تريد التحريض على الموقف الايراني
في نهايه المطاف الولايات المتحده
معذره
في نهايه المطاف الولايات المتحده تريد ان
تحرض المجتمع الدولي ضد ايران وبالتالي
ايران تقول بانها ليست اذا اردت
ساعود اليك بعد ان وجه سؤالا للسيد مايلز
هل هذا بالفعل من اجل التاليب والتحضير
ومن باب
المبالغه
لاهداف خاصه
وليس من باب ان هناك دقه في تحديد 12 يوما
على هذا النحو
ليس محاوله من جانب الولايات المتحده
لتحريض المجتمع الدولي ضد ايران بصراحه
ايران تفعل بنفسها ما فيه الكفايه لتحريض
المجتمع الدولي ضدها من دون اي مساعده
المتحده هذه الفتره التي فيها ايران
تستطيع
الحصول على كميات كافيه من اليورانيان
الخاصه بهذه مجرد حقيقه علميه تستند الى
معطيات لان حقيقه ما لدى ايران اذا كان
هناك
تسخين في المساله القنبله التي اسقطت على
هيروشيما كادت نسبه التخصيب فيها 80% فقط
ايران تجاوزت نسبه التخصيب من الان فهي
لديها لانتاج قنبله من الان سيد محمد
صدقيان تعليقك
يعني لحد الان ايران تقول بانها ليست في
وارد الاتجاه نحو انتاج السلاح النووي هذه
نقطه النقطه الثانيه
ايران اعلنت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بانها تريد رفع نسبه التخصيب الى
60% الان هناك
اثنان من المفتشين التابعين للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه زاروا مواقع نوويه
ايرانيه وتحديدا منشاه فردو احد المفتشين
هو الذي قال بان هناك تخصيب يزيد على
الستين بالمئه ويصل الى
83%
المتخصصون في القضايا
في انشطه التخصيب يقولون
المتخصصون في انشطه التخصيب اعود اليك
اعود اليك لا باس بان هذه النسبه لا حتى
تتخلص فقط من هذه الحشره
ساعود اليك سيد مايل بامبرز
يعني في نهايه المطاف ما الذي يمكن ان ان
يترتب على هذا الموقف الامريكي
يجب ان نكون واضحين ان هناك مرحلتين
لامتلاك ايران قنبله نوويه وهو الجزء
العلني اي مرحله
التخصيب والان نقول انها فصحه 12 يوما
المرحله الثانيه والتحويل المواد
الانشطاريه الى قنبله هذا قد يستغرق عددا
من الاشهر حتى ربما سنوات لن نستطيع
رؤيتها بالطبع لانه سيتم بعيدا عن الانظار
من دون قدره الوكاله الدوريه للطاقه
الذريه للاطلاع على مجريات الامور اذا
الامر الاول هو اذا كانت ايران ليست بوارد
صنع قنبله اذا عليها ان تسمح للوكاله
الدوليه للقيام بالتفتيش والوصول الى
المنشات كما طالب الدكتور غراسي
بان يدخلوا الى كل المنشات وان يطلعوا على
كل
الوثائق لو ان ايران لا تسمح بهذا هذا هذا
واضح على نواياهم ايضا ايضا ستين في المئه
تخصيب ليس ضرويا كذلك لان ايران بامكانها
وامكان منشاتها ان تشتغل بعشرين في المئه
وخمسه في المئه حتى الستون في المئه اصلا
كانت زائده عن الحد فايران هي التي تجعل
مجتمع الدولي يتصور انها بصدد انتاج قنبله
نوويه
في الحقيقه
حسب المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفيق روسي والذي سيصل الى طهران
الجمعه يتحدث عن
83.7 في المئه
ما تقوله الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ان هذا لا يت سق مع ما تعلنه ايران
دعني اشير الى نقطه في غايه الاهميه وهي
الثقه المفقوده بين ايران والوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
هذه الثقه كنا نامل ان يتم تعزيزها بعد
التواصل بين ايران وخمسه زائد واحد
للاتفاق النووي لكن يبدو بان الانسحاب
الامريكي من الاتفاق النووي لم يستطع من
تعزيز الثقه بين الجانبين وبالتالي انا
اعتقد
بان زياره جروسي يوم الجمعه الى طهران اذا
استطاعت من تعزيز الثقه بين الجانبين ان
يعتقد بانه يخدم ايران يخدم الوكاله
الدوليه ويخدم كل الاطراف المعنيه بهذا
الملف وبالتالي هناك الكثير من السلوك او
الخطوات التي تبعتها الولايات المتحده
لوكاله الولايات المتحده من ضغوط على
الوكاله الدوليه من الكثير من الاعمال من
فرض عقوبات على ايران وبالتالي يبدو لي
بان الجميع الاطراف المعنيه بالبرنامج
النووي الايراني يستطيع ان يعزز الثقه لان
فقدان الثقه لا يخدم ايران لا يخدم
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لا يخدم
بقيه الاطراف وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان هذه
زياره تاتي في توقيت مهم وتاتي في في اطار
مهم من اجل تعزيز الثقه
نامل ان يكون السيد جروسي يتم المهنيه
كافيه من اجل تعزيز الثقه مع الجانب
الايراني
لازاله هذا القلق الموجود بين ايران
والوكاله الدوليه وبين ايران ومع مجموعه 5
+ 1 من اجل ابداء المزيد من الشفافيه في
البرنامج النووي الايراني وهذا يعتمد
كثيرا كما اعتقد على تعزيز الثقه بين
ايران والوكاله الدوليه الطاقه الذريه
وهذا الامر يبدو لي بانه يعتمد كثيرا على
تصرف الوكاله الدوليه مع البرنامج النووي
الايراني ومع الجانب الايراني شكرا جزيلا
لك اذا محمد صالح صدقيان الباحثه المتخصص
في القضايا الاقليميه حدثنا من طهران
واشكر كذلك من واشنطن مايلز كبير الباحثين
في مركز جيمس مارتن لدراسات الحاده من
الانتشار النووي
في فقره المتابعه سنعود الى الارقام
والنسب ودلالاتها ونسال ضيفنا متى يكون
مستوى التحصيل مقلقا وقابلا للاستخدام
لاغراض عسكريه
في ملف الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اعلن
الجيش الروسي تصديه لهجوم اوكرانيا كثيف
بمسيارات على شبه جزيره القرم يتزامن
الهجوم مع احتدام المعارك على الجبهه
بخموت الاستراتيجيه شرقيه البلاد بين
القوات الاوكرانيه ومليشيا فاجنر وفي حديث
عن الحرب من واشنطن اعلن وزير العدل
الامريكي ان بلاده تحقق في كيفيه دخول
اجزاء امريكيه المصدر في بعض المسيرات
والصواريخ التي سقطت في اوكرانيا
المحور الاصعب
ذاك تشخيص الرئيس الاوكراني لجبهه بخموت
التي يحتدم فيها القتال بين قوات بلاده
وميليشيا فاجنر مؤسس الميليشيا تحدث عن
تعزيزات اوكرانيه ترسل للمدينه التي تزداد
المعارك فيها دمويه وفق قوله
الجيش الاوكراني يرسل جنودا اضافيين الى
باخمت عشرات الالاف من الجنود الاوكرانيين
يقاومون بغضب ودمويه المعارك تزداد يوما
بعد يوم
وفق موقع ريبار العسكري الموالي لروسيا
تقدم مقاتلوفاجنر في الجبهه الشماليه
الغربيه للمدينه باتجاه خروموفا اخر طرق
امداد الجيش الاوكراني وتقدمت فاجنر ايضا
من جهه الشرق حتى اقتربت من نهر باخمت وفي
الوقت نفسه تحاول مواصله التقدم من الجنوب
لاكمال تطويق المدينه
بالمقابل سبق ان اعلنت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه صد خمسه وثمانين هجوما روسيا
على جميع المحاور في بخمت واصفه الوضع
بالصعب والمتوتر وهو ما جعل فكره الانسحاب
الاوكراني من المدينه مطروحه كما نقل عن
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني لكن سرعان ما
خرجت نائبه وزير الدفاع متحدثه عن خسائر
من وصفتهم بالمحتلين وعن احباط القوات
الروسيه ومؤكده التمسك باستعاده السيطره
على المدينه
وقرار تمسك بباخ قرار استراتيجي وليس
سياسيا يتخذه العسكريون الذين لا توجههم
الدوافع السياسيه
ضخمه هي الجهه الاسخن لكنها ليست الوحيده
بالطبع تتحدث القوات المواليه لروسيا في
دونيتسك عن قصف اوكراني على احياء سكنيه
خلف خسائر بشريه واضرارا في المباني
والبنيه التحتيه والى الجنوب هاجمت
اوكرانيا بكثافه شبه جزيره القرم وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها احبطت ذلك
الهجوم دون خسائر
تم احباط محاوله هجوم مكثفين بطائرات
مسيره على منشات في شبه جزيره القرم من
قبل نظام كييف واسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
6 مسيرات هجوميه اوكرانيه وتم تعطيل اربع
مسيرات اخرى من قبل وسائط الحرب
الالكترونيه
بالمقابل يتحدث الجيش الاوكراني عن مضاعفه
روسيا عدد سفونها في البحر الاسود الى
سبعه عشره سفينه منها خمس حاملات صواريخ
وغواصتان وفق ما نقلته وسائل اعلام محليه
عن القياده الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه
تزداد مساحه لتصعيد وتراشق بين واشنطن
وبيجين اخر الفصول ملف تطبيق تيك توك الذي
تقول واشنطن انه يهدد امنها القوميه حيث
مررت لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مشروع قرار يمنح الرئيس الامريكي
صلاحيات جديده لمنع التطبيق والتطبيقات
اخرى مملوكه اجنبيا في الولايات المتحده
وفي تصريحات صحفيه اعرب رئيس اللجنه
النائب الجمهوري مايك ماكول الذي تقدم
بمشروع القرار عن اعتقاده بان مجلس النواب
سيصوت في المنظور القريب على مشروع القرع
الاتهامات الامريكيه ذهبت الى مساحه
اضافيه اليوم حيث قال مدير مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الامريكيه
ان المكتبه بحث في اصل جائحه كورونا وتوصل
الى انه كان على الارجح حادثا معمليا في
مدينه ووهان في الصين واضاف اليه في
مقابله مع قناه فوكس نيوز ان عمل الاف بي
اي بشان تحديد مكان نشوء الوباء لا يزال
مستمرا لكن العديد من التفاصيل المتعلقه
بالتحقيق لا تزال سريه مشيرا الى انه
يعتقد النبيجين تعمل على تقويض التحقيق من
جانب الولايات المتحده واعضاء اخرين في
المجتمع الدولي
هذا الحديث ردت عليه المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه الولايات المتحده دعت
الولايات المتحده الى احترام العلم
والحقائق وتجنب تسييس مساله البحث عن اصل
فيروس كورونا وقالت ماونا بيجين تعرض بشده
تدخل وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه في تتبع
منشا الفيروس
في مساله تتبع اصل الفيروس وتدخل وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه في القضايا العلميه
هو في حد ذاته تسييس لقضيه تتبع المنشا لا
توجد مصداقيه على الاطلاق في استنتاجاتهم
التي تستند الى تاريخ الاحتيال والخداع
الاستخباراتي الامريكي يحث الولايات
المتحده على احترام العلم والحقائق وعدم
تاسيس تتبع اصل فيروس كورونا والتوقف عن
الانخراط في التتبع الاستخباراتي والتوقف
عن تقويد البحث العلمي في سياق متصل قالت
المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده
لندى توماس ان بلادها منخرطه في منافسه
استراتيجيه مع الصين لضمان سياده قيم
الديمقراطيه والحريه وحقوق الانسان على حد
تعبيرها
بدون قيادتنا تامل الصين وروسيا واخرون في
رسم شكل الامم المتحده والعالم في صوره
استبداديه وهذا ما لم نسمح به حيث نحشد
الحلفاء والشركاء لمعالجه النزاعات والجوع
وتغير المناخ وانتهاكات حقوق الانسان
وغيرها نحن منخرطون في منافسات استراتيجيه
خاصه مع الصين لضمان ان تسود قيم الحريه
والديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
هذا ويشوب العلاقات التجاريه بين الولايات
المتحده والصين توتر متزايد منذ السياسات
التي تبعتها واشنطن
تتمثل هذه السياسات بما بات يعرف بالحرب
التجاريه بنى اداره ومن ثم القيود التي
فرضتها اداره بايدن في اكتوبر الماضيه على
تصدير الرقائق الالكترونيه واشباه
الموصلات في سلسله تقاريرنا الخاصه بملف
التوتر في شرق اسيا اسلط الضوء في التقرير
التالي على طبيعه العلاقه بين الاقتصاديين
الصيني والامريكي وما يمكن ان تؤدي اليه
العقوبات الامريكيه على الصين من توترات
بلغه الارقام تبدو العلاقه بين اكبر
اقتصادين في العالم في احسن حال كيف لا
وقد فاقد تبادل التجاري بين الولايات
المتحده والصين
650 مليار دولار في العام 2021 اي بزياده
بلغت 100 مليار دولار عن العام 2020
لكن الارقام لا تخفي التحولات التي طرات
على تقييم الولايات المتحده لعلاقاتها
التجاريه مع الصين من علاقات تصب في مصلحه
واشنطن الى تهديد في قطاعات منها للامن
القومي الامريكي خلال العقدين الماضيين
انتقلت الولايات المتحده من دعم انضمام
الصين الى منظمه تجاره العالميه تحت اداره
الى محاوله تعزيز المنافسه ضدها من خلال
مبادره الشراكه عبر المحيط الهادئ للتجاره
الحره في عهد باراك اوباما ثم فرض عقوبات
اقتصاديه على بيجين فيما عرف بالحرب
التجاريه ابان اداره دونالد ترامب وصولا
الى محاوله اقصائها بالكامل عبر فرض قيود
على تصدير اشباه الموصلات الى الصين فيما
بات يعرف بالحرب البارده الجديده في ظل
اداره جو بايدن
هذه التطورات جاءت نتيجه تغيرات طرات في
الولايات والصين بشكل عام تعزز المنحى
السلطاوي في الصين التي تراجعت عن اصلاحات
اقتصاديه كانت تشير الى امكانيه ادماجها
في النظام الدولي القائم على القواعد بما
يخدم المصالح الامريكيه وفي الولايات
المتحده زاد التشكيك بالتجاره عموما ومع
تطور الصين دخلت في منافسه اكبر مع
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي انخرطت في
نزاعات اكثر معنا يصف عدد من الخبراء قرار
اداره بايدن في شهر اكتوبر الماضي بفرض
قيود على تصدير اشباه الموصلات بالحرب
البارده الجديده على الصين بسبب حاجتها
الماسه الى هذه التكنولوجيا لتطوير
صناعاتها المدنيه والعسكريه في ان في
المقابل يبرز سؤال عن الرد الصيني واذا
كانت بيجينغ قادره على استغلال امتلاكها
لنحو 900 مليار دولار من الدين العام
الامريكي ورقه ضغط على واشنطن
اذا قر روا انهم يريدون الحاق الضرر
بالولايات المتحده من خلال بيع سندات
الخزانه واغراق السوق بها ودفع الاسعار
الى التهاوي الاجابه هي ان الامر سيخفض
قيمه هذه الاصول التي تمتلكها الصين
رغم مساعي اداره بايدن لفك الارتباط في
قطاعات تكنولوجيه حساسه بين الاقتصادين
الامريكي والصيني فان الصين تظل حاجه
اقتصاديه للولايات المتحده مع استحواذها
على نحو 30% من الناتج الصناعي العالمي
وتتربع على عرش الصادرات الصينيه الى
الولايات المتحده سلع حيويه للمستهلك
والصناعات الامريكيه على السواء وهي
الالكترونيات والمعدات الاليه والادوات
المنزليه والعاب الاطفال والالعاب
الالكترونيه والنسيج والبلاستيك والمطاط
والحديد والمفروشات والمواد الكيميائيه
ومع ذلك سلطه جائحه كورونا الضوء على
الدور الريادي بالصين في سلاسل التوريد
العالميه واثارت سياسه الاغلاق اضطرابات
في الاسواق العالميه ما دفع الولايات
المتحده وغيرها من الدول الى البحث عن
موردين اضافيين
سوف نرى انتقالا جزئيا لسلاسل التوريد
جراء تغييرات تطرا على الاساسيات
الاقتصاديه الصينيه بالاضافه الى الكيفيه
التي تعاملت بها حكومه الصين مع كوفيد 19
فضلا عن اجراءاتها المهدده وسياساتها
الاقتصاديه القصريه
سرعت جائحه كورونا منحا بدا يتبلور خلال
السنوات الماضيه يتمثل بهجره صناعات تعتمد
على كثافه اليد العامله من الصين الى كل
من فيتنام و ماليزيا والهند وبنجلاديش
وتايوان يضاف الى ذلك سياسه الصين زائد
واحد التي تتبناها شركات امريكيه لتنويع
سلاسل التوريد والتحوط ازاء مزيد من
التوترات في العلاقات بين واشنطن
التوترات الامنيه والسياسيه والتحولات
الاقتصاديه تدفع الولايات المتحده الى
الربط بين علاقاتها التجاريه بالصين وبين
المخاطر على امنها القومي دون وقوع طلاق
شامل انما في ظل انحسار تدريجي للتشابك
بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم فدي منصور
الجزيره واشنطن
معنى من واشنطن دينس وايلدر مدير المجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي السابق لشؤون الصين
ومن بيجين ينضم الينا فيكتور جاون نائب
رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه ابدا من واشنطن
سيد
[موسيقى]
ليندا توماس تقول ان بلادها منخرطه في
منافسه استراتيجيه مع الصين لضمان سياده
قيم الحريه وحقوق الانسان
والديمقراطيه هل بالفعل هذا هو ما يقلق
الولايات المتحده ام انه هناك امورا اخرى
خلف هذه السطور يمكنه ان ان تتفضل بشرحها
لنا
شكرا لكم اولا
العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه هي علاقات
معقده للغايه وتعمل على عده مستويات فهي
اكثر تعقيدا من العلاقه التي لدى كانت لدى
الولايات المتحده مع الاتحاد السوفيتي بان
الحرب البارده نعم انتم محقون في القول
بان حقوق الانسان عنصر مهم لكن هناك حقائق
اخرى وهي ان بين الصيغه المتحده علاقات
تجاريه ضخمه بلغت ارقاما قياسيه في العام
الماضي وهناك قضاء تتعلق بالحدود في بحر
جنوب الصين هناك مشكلات حول التايوان
وهناك
بالنسبه
كما نقول المتحده لا يوجد توصيف سهل
ومباشر لهذه العلاقه لكن طبعا هذا لا يعني
ايضا على ابواب نزاع نحن ممكن ان نكون
متنافسين لكن ليس بالضروره متعاديين في
العلاقات
ويصعب تبسيط هذا العلاقه لانها تحمل في
طياتها مجموعه من الامور المعقده سيد جاو
هل هكذا ينظر الصينيون الى الامر طرفان
متنافسان لكنهما ليس متعاديين لاننا كثيرا
ما نسمع تصريحات حاده وتوتر وامور كثيره
للغايه
تطرحونه واحده من الاسئله الاهم في تاريخ
البشريه حاليا من منظور الصين الصين
المتحده بلدان مختلفان تماما ومهما كانت
نظره كل واحد منهم الى الاخر عليهما ان
يتعامله
مع بعضهم البعض لان الحرب ليست خيارا بين
الصين والمتحده وعلى كذا البلدين يتعاملون
مع بعضهما البعض عندما نتحدث عن التنافس
طبعا
ماذا
تتنافس الصين مع امريكا هل نتنافس في مجال
كره السله او لعبه كره المنفذه هذا ليس هو
الموضوع نحن يجب ان نكمل بعضنا البعض
الاخر وليس ان نتنافس الحديث
العذاب والتنافس هذه لا توصل لهذه النتيجه
هي طرق مسدوده النهايات نحن بلدان اعتبروا
الاقوى عسكريا في العالم يجب ان لا نتحدث
عن اي نديه وتنافس امريكا تعاني من مشكلات
هي تخاف من الصين ستنمو وتتقدم عليها
وتتجاوزها لان الانتاج الصناعي الصيني
يفوق من الان انتاج امريكا واليابان
والمانيا مجتمعه ايضا امريكا خائفه من ان
الصين عندما تتجاوزها
الصين ستفرض قيمها وثقافتها
على راتب وهذا خطا تماما
هذه هذا السبب امريكا تحاول تصميم العلاقه
مع الصين الصين لا في الماضي ولا في
الحاضر ولا في المستقبل لا تريد ان
زعيمه العالم لا نريد فرض نظامنا القيامنا
على اي بلد الولايات المتحده لها الحق ان
تسعى وراء نظامها الخاص كما للصين الحق في
ان تسعى الى نظامها الخاص دعنا نسمح لكل
بلد يعيش ويترك غيره يعيش هذا هو السبيل
الوحيد للصين المتحده ان تتعاملها مع
بعضهما او مع اي بلد اخر اصير لا تريد ان
تكون السيد على العالم ولا ينبغي لامريكا
ان تكون السيد على الصيد نحن يجب ان
نتجاوز
ونتعامل مع بعضنا البعض على قدم المساواه
بدلا من الانخراط في خيارات التسارع مع
الصين ودون التفكير بالمالات والنتائج
السيد فيكتور جاو اعتبر هذا اهم سؤال
بتاريخ البشريه واعتقد ما يعنيه هو ان
العالم لا يمكن ان يتحمل صراعا عسكريا بين
الجانبين اذا ما هي الخيارات الموجوده في
هذا الذي وصفته بالتنافس وليس العداء بين
الصين والولايات المتحده ما هي خيارات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كيف يمكن ان
توقف التنين الصيني القادم بقوه والذي
يقلقها انجاز التعبير
الرئيس بايدن الرئيس تشيلسي في لقائهما في
بالي في العام الماضي كان واضحين تماما ان
لا احد منهم ما يريد
نزاعا وانا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده لا
تريد
النزاعا لكن الدكتور قال لم يكن تماما
صريحا عندما قال ان الصين تريد ان تعيش
وتترك الاخرين يعيشون فكان للصين اعمال
عدائيه
ونشاطات عسكريه متواصله تقترب من حدود
تايوان قطعت عسكريه سفن طائرات تحلق
الاجواء صواريخ تعبر اجواء تايوان والصين
ايضا تدعم كوريا الشماليه في بناء قدراتها
النوويه ما نريده ان يكون هناك
البحر
المحيط اله
الهادف مكان رقعه جغرافيه مفتوحه من دون
ان تسمح
للنزاعات لكننا نحن نرى ان الصين تريد
تغيير الوضع حسب مراميها
وتحاول توحيد ضمت تايوان اليها عن طريق
القوه بدلا من السماح للشعب التايوان ان
يختار لنفس اذا كثير من سلوكيات بيجين
تختلف عن تصريحاتها الشفهيه وهذه هي
الجوهره القضيه والمشكله
ما الذي يمكن ان يصل اليه ما هو اقصى شيء
يمكن ان يصل اليه الصراع بين الطرفين
تنتقد اننا اذا استمعنا الى الضيف الكريم
ومقاله عن تايوان ستعرفون مدى عدم منطقيه
وقاعده القانونيه الموقف الامريكي لقضيه
كايوان قضيه
واضحه قبل مده كان هناك صين واحده
والصين خاضت حرب استقلال
وانفصل عن الصين الام اذا هذه حرب اهليه
لم تحسم في العام 79
اللتر المتحده راهنت على الحصان الرابع
سحبت قواتها من تايوان واعترفت بالصين
واعترفت
بتصير دوره الصين الشعبيه كل هذه الامور
كانت تبدو مستحيله
المتحده لكنه فعلوا هذا الاعتراف
بالجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه ناولات المتحده
تريد لعبه ورقه تايوان وتتعامل معها بلد
مستقله سيادته كلا هذا ليس صحيحا الموقف
الرسمي الامريكي منذ العام 79
يعترف بوجود صين واحده واكد على ذلك وان
تايوان جزء من الصين لذلك توحيد الصين مع
تايوان هو امر حاصل لا محال هذا مهم في
واذا اعتبرتم توحيد تايوان مع الصين
سميتموه
عدوانا كنت ستصابون الرئيس
لينك معتديا عندما وحد شمال وجنوب الوطني
دعونا نسمر اشياء شكرا باسمائها
من بيجين كما اشكر ايضا السيد
وايلدر من واشنطن
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه هذا تذكير
بابرز عناوين
في تصعيدها المتواصل قوات الاحتلال تقتله
فلسطينيا خلال اقتحامها مخيمه عقبه جبر في
اريحا وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي يدعو لمحو
قريه حواره والخارجيه الامريكيه تصف
تصريحاته بالمقززه وغير المسؤوله وتدعو
نتنياهو لادانتها والمقرره الامميه لحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه تؤكد
للجزيره انها ستحقق في استخدام اسرائيل
مدنيين دروعا بشريه
وكاله الطاقه الذريه تقول في تقرير اطلعت
عليه الجزيره انها عثرت في ايران على
جزيئات ايرانيوم بنسبه تخصيب عاليه تناهز
90% وهي النسبه اللازمه لصنع قنبله
النوويه واشنطن تقول ان طهران زادت من
تخصيب اليورانيوم منذ انسحاب واشنطن من
الاتفاق النووي ووزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
يقول ان واشنطن غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار
شجاع بالعوده للاتفاق
على وقع معارك الشرق الجيش الاوكراني يؤكد
تقدم القوات الروسيه في باخموت ويعلن عزمه
ارسال تعزيزات اضافيه
[موسيقى]
تقول انها تواصل تقدمها موسكو تعلن احباط
هجوم اوكراني كبير بالطائرات المسيره على
شبه جزيره القرم وواشنطن تتحدث عن وجود
اجزاء امريكيه المصدر في مسيرات وصواريخ
سقطت في اوكرانيا
في فصل جديد من التوتر مع الصين لجنه في
مجلس النواب الامريكي توافق على مشروع
قانون يسمح بحظر تطبيق تيك توك مسؤول في
الاف بي اي يرجح فرضيه تسرب بفيروس كورونا
من مختبر صيني وبيجين تشكك في مصداقيه
الاستنتاجات الامريكيه وتقول انها تلاعب
سياسي
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان فلسطينيه
نستشهد متاثرا بجروح حرجه اصيب بها برصاص
الاحتلال خلال اقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر في
مدينه اريحا وقد انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من داخل المخيم بعد ان اقتحمته
بحجه اعتقال منفذي الهجوم المسلح الذي ادى
الى مقتل مستوطن الاثنين الماضي واعتقلت
سته فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين واصلت قوات
الاحتلال حصار بلده حواره والقرى القريبه
جنوبيه نابلس منذ الاحد الماضي
مره اخرى تخرق السلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كل التفاهمات السياسيه ففي وضح
النهار اقتحمت مخيم عقبه جابر في اريحا
قوه مستعربين تسللت بسياره فلسطينيه
مدعومه بحشد من جنود واليات الاحتلال
حاصروا منزلا اصابوا فلسطينيين بالرصاص
اعتقلوا عددا اخر
واحتجزوا ابا وطفله كدرع بشري بعدها
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال من داخل المخيم
متلقيه تهاني وزير الدفاع ومبقيه حواجز
عسكريه تطوق المحافظه
اما في حوار الجنوبيه نابلس فابقى
الاحتلال حصاره العسكري عليها منذ الاحد
الماضي حواره التي صرح زعيم الصهيونيه
الدينيه بوجوب محوها من الوجود
يعني يجب محو قريه حوار من الارض على
اسرائيل القيام بذلك وليس المدنيين
رئيس الحكومه الفلسطينيه زار مع وفدا من
الوزراء البلده وصف ما وقع فيها الاحد
الماضي بالجريمه اسرائيل الان تريد اعاده
انتاج النكبه سواء كان على شكل مذابح او
سواء كان على شكل تهجير او غيره لذلك
رسالتنا واضحه لا نكرر ما جرى في التاريخ
احنا موجودين هون على ارضنا صامدين
اما الحصار العسكري المتواصل لقريه ضمن
قرى تربط شمال الضفه الغربيه بوسطها فثبت
الاهالي خسائر ماليه فادحه وانسانيه صعبه
مرتي معها سرطان دور مش قادر اجيبها الدور
يعني ما يخلف رئيس البلديه عبالي مي
بصعوبه وصلته اعطاني عبالي مي يعني الوضع
عندنا ماساه ماساه ماساه طلع لنا طلع
المستوطنين طلع الجيش على راسي عليهم
مشاهدوا دفعت مؤسسات وفعاليات الى التحذير
مما هو قادم نحن مقبلين على مجازر ومحارق
قادمه لا محاله المستوطنين حملوا السلاح
باذن من حكومتهم ووزعوا السلاح وهم
ارهابيين مدربون يساعد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عمليات القتل والحرق والتدمير
والتهجير ويمارس اجراءات انتقاميه بحق
الاسرى ويفرض عقوبات جماعيه ويرى
الفلسطينيون في الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
جرائم مكتمله بغطاء سياسيا وامنيا من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه الجزيره من
بلده حواره جنوبينابلس
ووصف المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه نيد
برايس تصريحاتي وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
بتسلقيل سموتريتش الدعايته
لمحو الداعيه لمحوي قريه حوار الفلسطينيه
بغير المسؤوله والمثيره للاشمئزاز على حد
قوله ودعا برايس رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
الى رفض هذه التصريحات بشكل عالمي مشيرا
الى انها تحرض على العنف وفق تعبيره
اريد ان اكون واضحا بشكل لا لبس فيه هذه
التصريحات غير مسؤوله وبغيظه ومثيره
للاشتزاز وكما ندين التحريض الفلسطيني على
العنف فاننا نعرب عن ادانتنا لهذه
التصريحات الاستفزازيه التي ترقى ايضا الى
التحريض على العنف ندعو رئيس الوزراء
باليمين نتنياهو وغيره من كبار المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين الى رفض هذه التعليقات
والتنصل منها علنا وبوضوح اننا ندين
الارهاب والتطرف بالجميع اشكاله باستمرار
وما زلنا نحث على وجود تدابير متساويه
للمسائله عن الاعمال المتطرفه بغض النظر
عن خلفيه الجناه او الضحايا اعربنا عن
قلقنا حيل العنف العشوائي الواسع النطاق
من قبل المستوطنين ضد المدنيين
الفلسطينيين في حواره
فالمقر الخارجي الامريكيه في واشنطن معنا
مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم احمد لا اذكر
انني سمعت نيد برايس او اي متحدث باسم
الخارجيه او البيت الابيض
يستخدم عبارات كهذه عند الحديث عن تصريحات
وزير اسرائيل
نعم عثمان هي تصريحات او لغه تستخدمها غير
مسبوقه وغير معتاده من المسؤوليه
الامريكيين عندما يتحدثون عن تصريحات
اسرائيليه حتى وان كانوا قد انتقدوها في
السابق استخدام مصطلح مثير للاشمئزاز مقزز
لعل هذه التصريحات ومطالبه صريحه من على
منبر الاحاطه اليوميه لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي من يمين نتنياهو برفض هذه
التصريحات باعتبارها تحريضا مباشرا على
العنف ضد قريه حواره هناك في فلسطين وضد
الفلسطينيين الساكنين فيها اهالي هذه
القريه هذا بالتحديد ما ذكره ان هذا تحريض
للعنف على سكان هذه القريه وقد سمعنا من
الجانب الامريكي تصريحات ايضا انتقالات
لاذعه على عنف المستوطنين في الاسبوع
الماضي والقول او اتهام القوات
الاسرائيليه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
بانها لا تقوم بالتصدي
لعنف المستوطنين حاول وقفه هناك تصعيد
متدرج في الموقف الامريكي في الخطاب
الامريكي في اللهجه الامريكيه في تعاطيها
مع ازدياد العنف في الضفه الغربيه وعمليات
الاقتحام المتكرره للقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه وسقوط كعدد كبير من الضحايا
المدنيين خصوصا وان هناك جدل وحوار مستمر
منذ مقتل واغتيال الزميله شيرين بين
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل لتغيير قواعد
الاشتباك ولا يبدو ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
او السلطات الاسرائيليه مستعده لسماع هذا
المطلب الامريكي او الضغط او الاستجابه
للضغوط الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بتغيير قواعد
الاشتباك لتجنب سقوط مدنيين وهذا يثير
حفيظه الاداره الامريكيه ولاحظنا في
الفتره الاخيره منذ استلام او عوده
بنيامين نتنياهو الى رئاسه الوزراء نوع من
الامتعاض الامريكي من المواقف التي تخرج
من اسرائيل سواء فيما يتعلق
المستوطناتهم يتعلق بتقنين بعض المستوطنات
غير الشرعيه او زياده وحدات استيطانيه
جديده في الضفه الغربيه باعتبار ان هذا
هذه الاجراءات الاحاديه من الجانب
الاسرائيلي تقوض حول الدولتين اتحدث ايضا
بان هذا الاقتحام الذي جرى اليوم
والتصريحات التي ظهرت بخصوص الحواره هي
جاءت في اعقاب اتفاق يعول عليه الجانب
الامريكي اي اتفاق العقبه اذا التزم
الطرفان به لكنه جدد في هذه الاحاطه من ان
الاتفاق اذا كان مهما بحد ذاته عثمان فان
تطبيقه هو ما يجعل منه قيمه حقيقيه على
الارض ويؤدي ربما الى المطلب الامريكي وهو
خفض التصعيد اولا شكرا جزيلا لك احمد هزيم
من مقر وزاره الخارجيه في واشنطن
اقتحام الاربعاء تضمن مشهدا طرح كثيرا من
الاسئله حيث اكد شهود عيان داخل مخيم عقبه
جبران قوات الاحتلال اتخذت مدنيين دروعا
بشريه واظهرت صور توقيف قوات الاحتلال
لرجل يحمل طفلا الى جانب عربه عسكريه
يتجمع حولها جنود الاحتلال خلال دخولهم
للمخيم
من جانبها قالت مقرره الامم المتحده
الخاصه بحقوق الانسان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
ستحقق في واقعه استخدام قوات الاحتلال
لدروع بشريه خلال اقتحامها مخيمه عقبه جبر
وخلال مقابله مع الجزيره اكدت المقرره
الامميه ان استخدام الدروع البشريه من
الممارسات الشائعه لدى قوات الاحتلال
اسرائيل بصفتها قوه احتلال لديها مسؤوليه
حمايه حياه المدنيين سنحقق في هذه القضيه
وما حدث في مخيم عقبه جبر واؤكد ان
استخدام الدروع البشريه ممارسه شائعه من
قبل اسرائيل منذ عام
1967 فنرى استخدام مدنيين فلسطينيين
للوقوف امام الجنود وكذلك ان يطلب منهم
قرع الباب قبل الاقتحام منذ عام 2000
حاولت اسرائيل اتهام الفلسطينيين بانهم هم
من يستخدمون الدروع البشريه والحقيقه ان
اسرائيل هي من تقوم بذلك وعليه يجب اثبات
وتوثيق مثل هذه الممارسات التي تقوم بها
اسرائيل
يعرف القانون الدولي الدروع البشريه بانها
وضع مجموعه من المدنيين
او عسكريين بشكل متعمد حول الاهداف
العسكريه لردع العدو عن مهاجمتها وقد تاخذ
الدرع البشريه اشكالا اخرى كوضع المدنيين
او الرهائن امام قوات متقدمه لمنع العدو
من التصدي لها كما يصنف في خانه الدروع
البشريه تخزين اسلحه ومعدات وتمركز وحدات
عسكريه مقاتله في مناطق ماهوله بالمدنيين
يجرم القانون الدولي اقدام الاطراف
المتنازعه في الصراعات والحروب على
استخدام الدروع البشريه وفق اتفاقيتي جنيف
عام 1929 وعام
والبروتوكول الاضافي لها عام 1977
وايضا معاهده روما عام 1998
هذا وافاد تحقيق لنيويورك تايمز بان
الجنود الاسرائيليين استخدم القوه المميته
ضد الفلسطينيين العزل في نابلس في 22 من
فبراير الماضي مما اسفر عن مقتل اربعه
اشخاص على الاقل واضافت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز في تحقيقها ان من استهدفهم الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يبدو انهم يشكلون تهديدا
من رام الله معنا الدكتور غسان الخطيب
والساده العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت
ومن واشنطن معنا بريت بروين مدير التعاون
الدولي السابق في البيت الابيض خلال اداره
الرئيس باراكا اوباما
سيد بروين استمعنا الى لغه غير مسبوقه من
نت برايس يصف تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه الذي يطالب بمحو قريه حواره
بانها مقززه ما الذي يمكن ان نفهمه من هذه
اللهجه التي تحدث بها المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه وما الذي يمكن ان
يترتب عليها
اعتقد انك ما ذكرت من قبل ان اداره بايدن
وضعت في موقف صعب الان وبدانا نرى ان
الجهود الاداره لفرض ضغوط اضافيه على
الرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ووزرائه وبدانا
نرى بعض
النتائج من ذلك الضغط والذي تمثل في
الحوار وبعض التفاهمات والاتفاقات بين
الجانب الاصلي وحكومه نتنياهو وواضحون ان
هناك الكثير من الامور التي يمكن ان تنحو
منحا خاطئا راينا من واشنطن كيف ان اداره
باشر بايدن وصلت حدودها وهي مستعده من
وراء الكواليس وبشكل المتزايد علنا
بالافصاح عن مشاعرها هذه دكتور غسان
الخطيب هل يطمح الفلسطينيون بان يكون هناك
ضغط امريكي حقيقي على الاسرائيليين
في الحقيقه لا نتوقع ذلك لانه اتفق بانه
اللغه المستعمله في هذه التصريحات جديده
ولكنها تبقى في نطاق
الردود الفعل اللفظيه ومن تجربتنا الطويله
مع اسرائيل
وفيما يتعلق في العلاقات الاسرائيليه
الامريكيه فان اسرائيل لا تاخذ على محمل
الجد ردود الفعل طالما بقيت في النطاق
اللفظي اسرائيل تاخذ ردود الفعل بشكل جدي
اذا تعدت الادانه اللفظيه
واخذت اشكالا عمليه واظن ان الاداره
الامريكيه بعيده عن ان تاخذ خطوات ضاغطه
بشكل فعلي خارج نطاق ردود الفعل اللفظيه
المطلوب تطوير
ردود الفعل الامريكيه لترقى الى مستوى
عملي لممارسه الضغوط على هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لكي تمتثل على الاقل للرؤيه
الامريكيه
التي مثلا تعتبر بانه
الاستيطان مخالف للقانون الدولي ومخالف
لما تامل به الولايات المتحده من حل
الدولتين وغير ذلك
وانت مدير التعاون الدولي السابق في البيت
الابيض في اداره خلال اداره الرئيس باراك
اوباما هل يمكن ان تتجاوز ان يتجاوز
الموقف الامريكي مجرد كما قال الدكتور
الخطيب يعني الدائره اللفظيه لم يتعدى هذه
اللهجه التي استخدمها
كيف يمكن ان يكون الضغط الامريكي المتوقع
على على حكومه نتنياهو وحلفائه المتشددين
الامر الاول الذي ينبغي ان نقوله انه في
السياسه المتبعه هناك دائما اسلوب
بزياده شده الكلام التصريحات اللفظيه
بفرض ضغوط لفظيه اولا ربما تقترن ببعض
الضغوط الحقيقيه على قياده البلد المعني
وفي هذه الحاله نحن نتحدث عن اسرائيل في
ايام اوباما في عند عملته في البيت الابيض
واجهنا صعوبات كثيره في العلاقه مع حكومه
نتنياهو كثير من اعضاء فريق اذا انا ذاكي
يعمل حاليا ضمن اداره بايدن وهم يتذكرون
ما فعله وكيف كان لا يساعد على حلحله
الامور واضح هو الان يعاني من موقف الصعب
ليس في الخارج بل ايضا داخل بلاده اذا نرى
من جهه واشنطن تزيد من ضغوطها والشارع
الاسرائيلي يزيد ابن ضغوطه ينبغي ان يكون
هذا كافر لنتنياهو ليغير مساره غسان تعتقد
ان هذا قد يكون كافيا لنتنياهو ليغير
مساره
لا لا اعتقد ان هذا كافر على الاطلاق هناك
تاريخ طويل من العلاقات الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بالجهود الامريكيه
لثني اسرائيل عن ممارسات تراها الولايات
المتحده غير ملائمه ولكن في كل مره تبقى
هذه الضغوطات الامريكيه في نطاق
التصريحات اللفظيه
فعاده لا تبه اسرائيل ولا يابه نتنياهو
بمثل هذه الضغوط على الاطلاق فقط عندما
اخذت الولايات المتحده خطوات عمليه عندها
اسرائيل سواء كان نتنياهو او غيره يبداون
باخذ هذه المواقف الامريكيه على محمل الجد
وتترك اثرها على السلوك العمليه لماذا
خطوات عمليه التي تربط بين اشكال الدعم
الامريكي المختلفه لاسرائيل من ناحيه مع
السلوك الاسرائيلي على الارض من ناحيه
اخرى يعني يجب ان يكون هناك علاقه بين
الدعم الامريكي من ناحيه وبين السلوك
الاسرائيلي من ناحيه اخرى عدم استجابه
اسرائيل
للرغبات الامريكيه والتوجيهات الامريكيه
والانتقادات الامريكيه يجب ان يعكس نفسه
على اشكال الدعم الامريكي والاسناد
الامريكي لاسرائيل وبدون ذلك لن يكون هناك
اي تاثير كما علمتنا التجربه الحقيقه من
مثل هذه الانتقادات اللفظيه هناك فائده
فقط لاكون يعني واضح هناك فائده جانبيه من
الانتقادات الامريكيه لاسرائيل حتى
اللفظيه وهي ان هذا يشجع باقي دول العالم
التي اثر كثيرا بالموقف الامريكي على اخذ
مواقف يعني اكثر جراه في انتقاد اسرائيل
وربما يساعد ايضا في اخذ قرارات في هيئات
دوليه
فيها ادانه لاسرائيل وفيها ضغط على
اسرائيل سيد هل واشنطن مستعده لاتخاذ
الاجراءات عمليه من قبيله تلك التي اشار
اليها الدكتور غسان تربط الدعم الامريكي
لاسرائيل
بالممارسات التي تمارسها على الارض
ان هناك الى قدر الات المتحده على سبيل
المثال لم تغير موقفها فيما يتعلق بتقديم
الدعم العسكري لاسرائيل
القضيه مع ذلك ربما تقديم اشكال الدعم
الاخرى والفرص الاخرى
لاسرائيلين مطروح على الطاوله هناك خطوات
ليس بالضروره ان تكون خطوات كبيره
ربما خطوات صغيره مثل تاخيره الدعم او
تجميده او شيء انا اتفق مع الدكتور غسان
وحول قيام المتحده بخطوات مثل هذه سيشجع
بلدان اخرى لكي تقدم على خطوات اخرى او
ربما تصريحات او خطوات عمليه لان مثل هذه
صداها في انحاء العالم وكون الوقت المتحده
الدعم الاكبر لاسرائيل اذا ما زادت في
انتقاداتها اسرائيل هذا سيشجع بلدان اخرى
لتتخذ مواقف مشابهه تجاه اسرائيل شكرا
مدير التعاون الدولي السابق والبيت الابيض
خلال اداره الرئيس باراك اوباما ومن رام
الله الدكتور غسان الخطيب استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت
صدق الكنيسه الاسرائيلي في هذه الاثناء في
مناقشه اولى على مشروع قانون يقضي باعدام
اسرى فلسطينيين متهمين بتنفيذه هجمات الى
مقتل اسرائيليين وقد صوت لصالح مشروع
القانون 55 من نواب الائتلاف الحاكم وعرضه
تسعه كما شهدت الجلسه انسحاب عدد كبير من
نواب المعارضه الذين انضموا الى
المتظاهرين ضد مشروع تعديلات قضائيه تقدمت
به حكومه نتنياهو ولكي يصبح مشروع القانون
نافذا يحتاج الى التصديق عليه في ثلاث
مناقشات اخرى في الهيئه العامه للكنيست
واللجان التابعه له
معنا من كاليفورنيا كمقرر الامم المتحده
السابق لحقوق الانسان في فلسطين واستاذ
القانون الدولي في جامعه برنستن ام السيد
فوق ما الذي يمكن الاجراءات التي يمكن
اتخاذها ازاء هذه المشاهد التي شاهدناها
فيما يخص استخدام المدنيين
كدروع بشريه كما كما ظهر في صور فيديو
عرضناها على على شاشتنا
هذا هو جزء من قضيه اكبر والتي بحثها
ضيفكم السابق قبل قليل حول كيفيه تغيير
الدوله الامريكي فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه
باسرائيل
وهذا له تاثير محدود اذا اختصر الدوري
الامريكي على انتقاد استخدام القوه
المفرطه المستخدمه باشكال
متعدده بما في ذلك
الممارسات الشنيعه التي رايناها مثل
استخدامي الفلسطينيين كدروع بشريه هذا
يتجاوز اي مبدا واي مفهوم
للافعال الشرعيه التي تنص عليها
معاهدات جنابه وتقالاتها والقانون الدولي
الانساني ويجب ان نؤكد ان
القانون الدولي هذا يتناسب مع مثل هذه
التصرفات هل يمكن ان تفرض عقوبات حقيقيه
على الاسرائيليين بسبب هذا التصرف
ام يضر الامر يعني مجرد اجراءات هنا وهناك
بالطريقه التي ذرى فيها الامور في وضعها
الحالي
وبسبب راهنيه وعلاقه المشهد السياسي
الداخلي في الوقت المتحده وتاثيره في
العلاقه مع اسرائيل لا اتوقع ايه خطوات
غير لفظيه
ستكون هناك هذا الانتقاد سيكون هذه ستكون
هذه التصريحات لكن
لا شيء يكون ملموسا او يقع في خانه
السلوكيات التي يمكن ان يعتبرها اسرائيل
بانه بمثابه
التحول الضوء الاخضر الى ضوء اصفر على
الاقل نحن ما نتوقعه هو الضوء احمر في
الحقيقه
لكن
فيما يتعلق بالجوانب الاخرى وموقف المجتمع
الدولي الامر متروك لهم وللهيئات الدوليه
والمنظمات الدوليه ان تكون اكثر فاعليه في
التعامل مع هذه السكنات
كمقرر الامم المتحده السابق لحقوق الانسان
في فلسطين واستاذ القانون الدولي في جامعه
يوفنت
وس
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه في تقرير اطلعت عليه الجزيره ان
نتائج تحليل عينات في منشاه فوردو اظهرت
وجود جزيئات يورانيوم عالي تخصيب بنسبه
83.7 من اليورانيوم
واضاف التقرير الذي قدمه المدير العام
لمجلس المحافظين ان الوكاله ابلغت ايران
ان هذه النتائج غير متسقه مع مستوى
التخصيب الذي اعلنته طهران مطالبه بتوضيح
مصدر جسيمات اليورانيوم عالي التخصيب
واشارت تقريره الى ان الوكاله لم تتمكن من
القيام بمهام التحقق والرصد المنصوص عليها
في الاتفاق النووي سواء فيما يتعلق بانتاج
وجود وجرد اجهزه الطرد المركزي او انتاج
الماء الثقيل او تخصيب اليورانيوم لمده
عامين وافاد التقرير ان موظفي الوكاله لم
تكن لديهم القدره على التفتيش اليومي حسب
الطلب كما ينص على ذلك الاتفاق لمفاعلات
ناتنز وفوردو
وقال التقرير ان مفتشي الوكاله لم يكن
بامكانهم التثبت من ان اجهزه الطرد
المركزي وبنيتها التحتيه المخزنه قد بقيت
في مخازنها ام تم استعمالها لتعويض
الاجهزه المتضرره وذكر تقرير ان المفتشين
لم يستطيعوا التثبت من كميات المواد التي
دخلت في مراحل العمليات التخصيب لحسابها
بدقه وعزاء هذا القصور الى ما قال انه
قرار ايراني لازاله جميع معدات الوكاله
التي سبق تركيبها في ايران بانشطه
المراقبه والرصد وختم التقرير بان هذه
الاحداث تحد من قدره الوكاله على الكشف
والابلاغ في الوقت المناسب
هذا وجدد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
التزام بلاده بمنع ايران من الحصول على
سلاح نووي مضيفا ان الدبلوماسيه تبقى افضل
وسيله لتحقيق ذلك
برنامج ايران النووي ومنذ انسحاب الاداره
السابقه من خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
تعزز بشكل غير مقبول الرئيس بيضا تعهد
بالحرص على عدم امتلاك ايران لسلاح النووي
على الاطلاق وما زلنا نعتقد ان
الدبلوماسيه هي اكثر الوسائل الفعاله
لتحقيق ذلك لانها تبقى السبيل الوحيده
للتوصل الى تسويه دائمه نحن على ثقه تامه
بالالتزام الذي قطعناه على انفسنا بان
ايران لن تحصل على سلاح نووي وهذا مسعا
نتشارك فيه مع دول عده في اوروبا والشرق
الاوسط وغيرهما
وفي مقابله مع شبكه
حسين الامير عبد الله ان بلاده كانت ولا
تزال الاكثر التزاما من بين جميع الاطراف
المشاركه في المفاوضات في مفاوضات الملف
النووي واتهم الولايات المتحده بانها
تتبنى سلوكا مخادعا
فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق النووي كانت ايران
ولا تزال الاكثر التزاما الطرف الذي انسحب
منه هو ترامب والولايات المتحده على
الولايات المتحده الا تتبنى سلوكا مخادعا
وان تعود بدلا من ذلك الى الاتفاق وتتبنى
نهجا بناء في ظل الحكومه الجديده
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه قررنا
مواصله الحوار من اجل العوده الى الاتفاق
واجرينا مناقشات طويله للغايه في فيينا
قالت الولايات المتحده انها في مرحله
التوصل الى اتفاق لكن الايرانيين يطالبون
باكثر من اللازم صراحه في السنوات القليله
الماضيه راينا ان المسؤولين الامريكيين
غير قادرين على اتخاذ قرار بسبب مشاكلهم
الداخليه والضغوط التي يتعرضون لها
[موسيقى]
الى مشهد حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والتي
شهدت تطورا عسكريا لافتا اذا اعلن الجيش
الروسي انه تصدى لهجوم اوكراني كثيف
بطائرات مسيره على شبه جزيره القرم واوضحت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها صدت الهجوم
الاوكرانيه
يتزامن الهجوم مع احتدام المعارك على جبهه
باخموت الاستراتيجيه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه وميليشيا فاجنر وقال موقع
ريبار العسكريه التابعه لروسيا ان ميليشيا
فاجنر تقدمت في الجهه الشماليه الغربيه
لمدينه بخموت باتجاه بلده يخرموفا اخر طرق
امدادات الجيش الاوكراني في المدينه اضاف
الموقع عن تقدمت ايضا داخل مدينه ضخمه من
جهه الشرق واصبحت قريبه من نهر باخموتوفكا
وتحاول مواصله التقدم من الجنوب لاكمال
التطويق المدينه
هذا وقال رئيس مجموعه
الاوكرانيه ترسل تعزيزات اضافيه الى بخموت
وان المعركه هناك تزداد دمويه على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاوكراني يرسل جنودا اضافيين الى
باخموت ويحاول الاحتفاظ بالمدينه بكل قوته
عشرات الالاف من الجنود الاوكرانيين
يقاومون بغضب ودمويه المعارك تزداد يوما
بعد يوم
وعالم موسكو اندريه
والعسكري ومن كييف سيره كوزان المستشار في
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه سيد كوزان هل اذن
فاجنر مقتربه من الاطباق واحكام السيطره
على مخوت
علينا ان نقول انهم ليست قوات مختلف الفرق
العسكريه الروسيه تحاول ان تحاصر ضخم وهذا
ما يحاولون القيام به في اخر ست اشهر
والقوات
الاوكرانيه تاتي لهناك ويمدون ايضا القوات
تحصل القوات الروسيه على الذخيره وتحصل
على الاوامر بالمهمات ولكن قواتنا تقوم
بتدمير اعضاء العدو وجنوده
ونقوم بمد قواتنا بنظام مستمر كما ان
القياده للقوات
البريه زارت تلك المدينه
فلذلك المقاومه من طرفنا مستمر والمعارك
مستمره وهذه المعارك مستمره منذ سته اشهر
اذا لا معنى في الحقيقه للحديث عن اقتراب
السيطره الروسيه على بخموت لان هذا امر
استمر
لشهور في نهايه المطاف ولم يحدث
ليس هناك سيطره تامه ولكن اذا نظرنا الى
خطوط الجبهات والمعارك الجاريه سوف نرى ان
هناك تغيرات كثيره اذا كان قبل نصف سنه
اذا كانت القوات الروسيه غير متواجده في
المدينه فالان القوات الروسيه تحاصر
المدينه وتسيطر على الطرق المؤديه لها
وتقطع وتقطع جميع سكك الامدادات لذلك على
راي على حسب راي الخبراء ان
محاصره المحاصره التامه لباخ قريبه جدا
قريبه جدا نتحدث عن كم من الوقت لان اسبوع
او اسبوعين ليس كشهر او سته اشهر اخرى او
سنه
ليس سنه بالتاكيد ولكني اعتقد انه ليس اقل
ان هذا سوف يحتاج الى المزيد من الاسبوع
ليس اسبوع وليس اقل اعتقد ان معارك سوف
تستمر لاكثر من اسبوع سيد
قريب جدا اذا السيطره الروسيه ليس صحيحا
ان الروس بالفعل يحاصرون المدينه اليس
صحيحا انهم في الاشهر الماضيه تقدموا
كثيرا اليس صحيحا انهم
يحاصرون بخموت ويقطعون طرق الامداد
بالطبع
المحاولات المحاصره تستمر طوال اخر شهرين
ولكن يجب ان نقول ان
الاوضاع في تلك الجبهات ديناميكيه وبعض
المواقع
تنتقل من ايدي القوات الروسيه للاوكرانيه
والعكس طوالي المعارك والايام لذلك بخمد
والقوات الاوكرانيه هناك تقوم بالمهمات
الاهم
والمهمه هي استهداف قوه العدو وفي الواقع
ان القوات الروسيه هي من تقذف بنفسها للفخ
والقوات
الروسيه وقدراتها الهجوميه سوف تنتهي على
حدود ضخمه ومن الناس من يعتقد من الخ براء
ان استخدام ميليشيا هو في الحقيقه مؤشر
ضعف لقوه نظاميه يفترض انها
لاحد اقوى الدول العسكريا في العالم
لا ارى هنا اي مؤشر للضعف في الواقع ان
هذا امداد للقوات الروسيه وليس من السر ان
قوات فاجنر تقوم بالتنسيق مع الاداره
العسكريه الروسيه بشكل بشكل
مستمر ان الولايات المتحده ايضا تستخدم
خدمات الشركات العسكريه الخاصه وهذه امور
طبيعيه واذا نظرنا الى القوات الاوكرانيه
هناك الكثير من المناطق التي تحارب فيها
القوات التي لا تعتبر قوات اوكرانيا
نظاميه
السيد زرهي فاجنر كان لها تاثير كبير
وتحديدا في بخموت
طبعا هذا لا خلاف عليه لدى فاجنرز
لدى فاجنر البعض النجاح بسبب انها تضحي
باعداد كبيره من المساجين عن طريق قذفهم
الى الجبهات المشتعله في بخموت واليوم
الهيئه العسكريه
العليا
الروسيه تستفيد من هذه المغامرات من قبل
قوات فاجنر ويقوم بقذفهم على اكثر الجبهات
خطوره ونرى انه في الواقع
فاقنر تسير على جثث جنودها على جبهات
ضخموت ولكن يجب ان اقول انه بالطبع في
مختلف الدول يستخدموا القوات عفوا الشركات
الحربيه الخاصه ولكن ولكن فاقنر ليست شركه
خاصه بل انها مجموعه من القوات
المنتميه لروسيا شكرا جزيلا
وليس هناك اي دوله تستخدم السجناء
لضمهم الجيش النظامي كما تقوم بهذا روسيا
المستشار في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
واشكر من موسكو اندريه
السياسي والعسكري
[موسيقى]
تزداد مساحه
التصعيد والتراشق بين واشنطن وبيجين اخر
الفصول ملف تطبيق تيك توك الذي تقول
واشنطن انه يهدد امنها القومي وقد مررت
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مشروعه قرار يمنح الرئيس
الامريكي صلاحيات جديده لمنع التطبيق
وتطبيقات اخرى مملوكه اجنبيا في الولايات
المتحده وفي تصريحات صحفيه اعرب رئيس
اللجنه النائب الجمهوري مايك ماكول الذي
تقدم بمشروع القرار عن اعتقاده بان مجلس
النواب سيصوت في المنظور القريب على مشروع
القرع
الاتهامات الامريكيه ذهبت الى مساحه
اضافيه حيث قال مدير مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الامريكيه اف بي اي كريستوفر
ان المكتبه بحث في اصل جائحه كورونا وتوصل
الى انه كان على الارجح حادثا معمليا في
مدينه ووهان في الصين
ردت عليه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
وقالت ان الولايات المتحده يجب ان تحترم
العلم والحقائق وتتجنب تسييس مساله البحث
عن اصل فيروس كورونا
نعارض بحزم اي شكل من اشكال التلاعب
السياسي في مساله تتبع اصل الفيروس وتدخل
وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه في القضايا
العلميه هو في حد ذاته تسييس لقضيه تتبع
المنشا لا توجد مصداقيه على الاطلاق في
استنتاجاتهم التي تستند الى تاريخ
الاحتيال والخداع الاستخباراتي نحث
الولايات المتحده على احترام العلم
والحقائق وعدم تسييس تتبع اصل فيروس
كورونا والتوقف عن الانخراط في التتبع
الاستخباراتي والتوقف عن تقويض البحث
العلمي
في تركيا اعلن الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ان
انتخابات الرئاسه والبرلمان ستجرى في
موعدها في الرابع عشر من مايو عيار المقبل
واشار في كلمه امام كتلته البرلمانيه الى
ان هناك من يحاول استغلال الزلزال لاغراض
سياسيه من جهتها قالت زعيمه الحزب الجيد
المعارض من ميرال اكشنر قالت ان اراده
الشعب هي التي ستتجلى في الانتخابات
القادمه لا اهواء الافراد
سننهض ونحن اقواه يقول الاتراك فالكوارث
والمحن لا توقف الحياه جروب
ها هي ذي تركيا تقف على عتاب استحقاقات
سياسيه حاسمه لم ترى السلطات داعيا
لارجائها
هناك مغرضون يفرحون لرؤيه ما اسفرت عنه
الزلازل ظنا منهم ان الحكومه والدوله
والشعبه سيقعون تحت هذه الانقاض لكن على
هؤلاء الذين لم يذهبوا لمنطقه الزلازل ولم
يزور المنكوبين ان يعلموا ان الشعب التركي
سيرد على هؤلاء المغيطين في الرابع عشر من
مايو ايار المقبل قاده احزاب المعارضه
التي تبحث اسماء منافسين محتملين للرئيس
اردوغان سارعت بالفعل الى التشكيك في
كفاءه حكومته لاداره الكارثه ومن باب
النقد نفسه تجد حماسه في هذا المعسكر
للاحتكام الى الصندوق في الاجال المحدده
حان وقت الذهبي للانتخابات حان الوقت
لاسقاط الحسابات الشخصيه وعمل ما يلزم
لخدمه الامه والشعب لقد دمرت الحكومه كل
المؤسسات والمنظمات وحرفتها عن هدفها الذي
انشئت من اجله بعد 100 عام نرى مره اخرى
ان وحده وسلامه الوطن في خطر
لطالما اطلقت الكوارث الطبيعيه تداعيات
سياسيه اعلت الاستقطابات على حساب الوحده
يعتقد الرئيس اردوغان ان الاتهامات
بالتقصير في التعامل مع زلزال كهرمان مراش
وتوابعه تحركها دوافع سياسيه طلب الرجل
الصفحه عما سجل من تاخير في الايام الاولى
في تنظيم عمليات الاغاثه وتعهد بمحاسبه
جميع المقصرين قضائيا واداريا وسياسيا لكن
ذلك لا يزيح كل اللغات الذي يحيط
بانتخابات لن تجرى في الظروف نفسها التي
شهدها اقتراع عام 2018
سيكون التصويت نفسه تحديا في المحافظات
العشر الاكثر تضررا بالزلزال والخاضعه
لحاله طوارئ هناك يقطن نحو اربعه عشر
مليون شخص ما زال معظمهم يلملم جراحه
فمنهم من فقد الاحبه والماوى ومنهم من
يحتاج كهؤلاء الصغار لدعم نفسي كي
يستوعبها ما جرى
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى الى الملف النووي الايراني تقرير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التي يتهم
ايران بتخصيب اليورانيوم
يقول يتحدث عن 90% ويعيد مسلسل تبادل
الاتهامات بشان برنامج النووي للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه تملك طهران عده مفاعلات هي
مفاعل بالشهر الذي يقع في الجنوب ويعتبر
اول محطه للطاقه النوويه في ايران وهو
مفعل لانتاج الماء الخفيف ويمكن ان ينتج
ماده البلوتونيوم المنظم هناك كذلك مجمع
اصفهان النوويب والذي يقع وسط ايران ويعد
اهم منشاه نوويه في البلاد يضم اربعه
مفاعلات صغيره للبحوث النوويه ومركزا
للتكنولوجيا النوويه ومنشاه لتخصيب
اليورانيوم ومحطه انتاج المكونات والسبائك
اللازمه للمفاعلات النوويه مفاعل اراك يقع
شمال غربي البلاد ويعد اكبر منشاه نوويه
ايرانيه وهو بمثابه مفاعل نشط للمياه
الثقيله محطه فوردو لتخصيب اليورانيوم
وتقع جنوب طهران وقد اقيمت على عمق 80
مترا اسفل ان هرميه الشكل وهي محطه مخصصه
لتخصيب اليورانيوم الانشطاري بنسبه 20%
وقد اعترفت ايران بوجودها في سبتمبر 2019
محطه ناطانز وتقع وسط ايران بالقرب من
مدينه ناتنس وتعد اكبر منشاه طرد مركزي
لتخصيب اليورانيوم في البلاد تضم 7000
جهاز طرد مركزي 500 منها تنتج اليورانيوم
منخفضه تخصيب الذي يستخدم لانتاج وقود
لمحطات الطاقه النوويه ويمكنها ايضا انتاج
اليورانيوم عالي التخصيب
هناك نسبه
83% فاصل سبعه في المئه تتحدث عنها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وتقول ان
ايران بلغتها في منشاه فوردو وهي نسبه
تخصيب قريبه جدا من درجه النقاء المطلوبه
لصنع الاسلحه النوويه وهي 90 في المئه
وذكر تقرير وكاله ان طهران ابلغتها بان
التقلبات غير المقصوده في مستويات التحصيل
ربما حدثت خلال الفتره الانتقاليه وقت بدء
عمليه التحصيل لدرجه نقاء 60% في نوفمبر
2022 او في اثناء استبدال اسطوانه التغذيه
وافادت تقرير السري للوكاله بان طهران
واصلت في الاشهر الاخيره زياده مخزونها من
اليوراني والمقسم وانا المخزون ارتفع
الثاني عشر من فبراير الى ثلاثه.7 كلغ
مقابل 3.6 كلغ في اكتوبر بحيث تجاوز 18
مره السقف المسموح به في بنود الاتفاق
النووي لعام 2015
كان اتفاق ينص على عده قيود مشان برنامج
ايران النووي انها الا تتجاوز نسبه تقسيم
اليوراني 3.6% وهي النسبه الملائمه لتوليد
الطاقه النوويه لاغراض مدنيه بعد اغتيال
العالم فخر زاد في ضواحي طهران عام 2020
اعلنت الحكومه خطا لزياده مستوى تحصيب
اليورانيوم من اربعه ونصف في المئه الى
20% وزياده عدد اجهزه الطرد المركزي
المتطوره ايضا واعلنت ايران في ابريل عام
2021 انها ستزيد مستوى تحصيل اليورانيوم
لنسبه تصل الى 60% في منشات بمحافظه
اصفهان وسط البلاد من باريس ينضم الينا
طول الدرفمان وهو الخبير في الطاقه
النوويه في مركز ابحاث السياسات العلميه
في جامعه البريطانيه ورئيس المجموعه
الدوليه للاستشارات النوويه اهلا وسهلا بك
هل بالفعل كما قال مسؤول امريكي لسي بي اس
اليوم باتت ايران على بعد 12 يوما فقط من
انتاج قنب او صنع قنبله نوويه
طبعا انا اتحدث انا اتحدث
حسب الارقام التي ظهرت من الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه
الذريه وهي تتحدث عن
نسب تقل عن تسعين في المئه في وصلت اليها
من خلال المراقبين
مختلفه يمكن ان نتحدث عنها لاحقا
لما لم اسمع الاجابه
بالطبع يمكن ان نعيد الاجابه نحن نفهم
البواعث القلق العسكريه
الامريكيه لكن ايضا هناك كثير من الخبراء
ممن
يعتقدون ان امكانيه تصنيع ايران لسلاح
النووي او انتاج راس النووي على هيئه
صاروخ او نحو ذلك قد يحتاج الى نحو عام من
الان
يعني كم يجب ان تصل نسبه
التخصيب قبل ان تتمكن ايران من ذلك هل
عندما نتحدث عن نسبه قريبه من 90% نتحدث
عن انها بلغت النسبه التي تحتاجها في معدل
التخصيب مثلا
الله
يرانيوم الطبيعي هو بحدود اقل من واحد في
المئه ونحو ذلك انت تحتاج الى ثلاثه الى
خمسه في المئه لكي تستطيع تشغيل المفاعل
نووي مدني عندما تصل الى نسبه 20% اعتبر
هذا نسبه تخصيب عاليه للايرانيوم
ويعتقد ايضا ان ايران
تنتج يورانيوم مخصب
بمستوى 60% على مدى عام تقريبا وهذا يعني
انها وصلت مرحله
متقدمه
اليورانيوم المخصبه الذي نحتاج لانتاج
سلاح هو بحدود 90% من التقسيم لهذا السبب
من المهم ان نلاحظ
ان
[موسيقى]
اما يسمى
بنسبه
87 في المئه او اكثر من ذهب في قليل في
منشاه فوردو يتم هناك حديث عن ذلك بانه
يتم فعليا وايضا من المهم ان نلاحظ ان
يبدو ان هناك عناصر
لجسيمات من اليورانيوم التي
ربما
عثر عليها والتي تؤدي الى الاعتقاد بان
هناك ربما رغبه من ايران قبل العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي
وذلك
لتحديد احتمال سباق تسلح او جهود نحو سلاح
نووي شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس الدكتور بول
دوفمان خبير الطاقه النوويه في مركز ابحات
السياسات العلميه في جماعه ساسكا
البريطانيا ساسك البريطانيه ورئيس
المجموعه الدوليه للاستشارات النوويه
[موسيقى]
30 يوما دون طعام او شراب هذا هو ما حدث
لشاب بوليفين ضل طريقه وابتعد عن رفقاءه
بينما كانوا في رحله صيد في غابات
الامازون يقول جونسن انه كان يقتات على
الحشرات والديدان ويشرب من مياه تتجمع في
حذائه وانه كان يدعو الله ان ينزل الغيث
ولولا هطل الامطار بعد الايام ما كان
ليعيش كل هذه الفتره في عام
2021 امضى احد الناجين من تحطم طائره
سياحيه ثمانيه 38 يوما في الجزء البرازيلي
من غابات الامازون التي لا تتوقف عن انجاب
المعجزات انتبهوا جيدا شقيقان اصغرهما في
السابعه من العمر والاكبر في التاسعه عثر
عليهما صدفه بعد 25 يوما كان خلالها
يقتاتان على الفواكه البريه فقط لا تسالوا
عما بهما من عطش وج
الحمد لله على نعمه ليلتكم سعيده